[Musik]
juni klar mitarbeiterin für zwei junge
männer zum check-in beide in den east
stock trends im flugzeug
der 1
debtx westen über doch ob blick aus dem
fenster flugzeug fliegt über private
artige wolke spätere stadt am meer
[Musik]
jonas die schlankheit 13
mein name ist jonas events geschafft
sagte der abchasische hochschulinstitut
für berufsbildung und gesetze will sie
auch gar nicht mehr aber dank dem dass
immer noch achse einem ähnlich nur acht
gut auf arbeit in der ihf das ständige
schaltet die helfer nicht gut sie haben
dass er mit 1 geschafft
der fcb eine traiskirchen kanton
fribourg radiomachen verbrauch und die
gesetze prozent sieht wiedergeburt
in dieses stück folgt andere leitlinie
dem fernseher diesen vorschlag wird
heuer vor allem dank nur eine sache
endlich technik und die persönliche
becker ludwigshafen und da seien
unbedingt wohl zeigen wie wichtig dass
es sich dass man hilft dass man zeigt
dass man miteinander und die eigentlich
groß israel ein staat einmal im gespräch
mit dem fund im jonas der moderator
wissen reise häufig damit konfrontiert
wieso überhaupt aus plane ja dasselbe
hinter tiger karriere eigentlich gar
nicht der vfb mit dem büchermarkt statt
köhler habe darüber noch große blüten
lehrer keine dank der andere sind und
dank der weniger an ihm als er mehrfach
neben reise aussehen
die jonas tief berührende farbigem uhr
die beiden freunde steht neben den
anderen und lege die kamera ließ
aufschrift blindflug 1 sf dokfilm
[Applaus]
[Musik]
bis 15
ja
schade und sehr traurig
der wasserdruck
versucht ihr etwas jetzt tourismusbüro
das ist gerade aus und dann links ich es
noch gibt
nein es ist gleich nebenan unterschätze
platz zwölf das ziel befindet sich auf
ihren linken seite und der vibrierte und
aktuelle förder und
[Musik]
da
die erste information
sie war dahin dann müsst ihr die treppe
hoch ich würde es noch die alltagskomik
menschen einfach gastiert der praxis ist
ja nicht mit nicht planen so passiere
ich so viele überraschungen und so
friesacher und ja man kann es halt nicht
studie
das wollen wir nach jerusalem
berlin wenn wir mehr denn je als
rentabler ist es auch
[Musik]
hier ist ihr zimmer und das ist ihre
karte das ist der schlitz für die karte
bella schlitz hier
[Musik]
das ist für den strom da von links
stecken sie die karte rein
warten sie kurz und dann öffnet sich die
tür
hier ist das ja natürlich
geradeaus geht es zum badezimmer und zur
toilette
ach ja die gläser wasser früchte hier
ist der kaffee wenn sie hilfe brauchen
sagen sie jonas nachricht im fernsehen
wie zé roberto nicht griechenland
hier vermischen
mehrere tans einschätzt kulinarischer
gereizt aber auch so das geschichtliche
das hier so bedeutender ort ist für
viele surfer und denkt demokratie und
das habe außerdem die historische platz
interessiert
die zürcher denken
[Musik]
wow
unter den links abbog stieß aber würde
statt rettungskarte im auto
heute springt er ist eben auch leo
fossilis nach westen
vivico mit dem us-team das ist das beste
was station war er ganz klar
festgestellt
schon mal getroffen
mit black book muss ich
ja
sorry sorry
gebaut und allegretto story
cannabis frage ja gehts hier dürfte hier
in diese richtung
also das wichtigste ist
außer idee
ja ja
laut
super
wiesbaden das hat forscht nach unten
länger laufen ich denke das hätte ich
mir hier schon zweiter kategorie h50
hast du schon mal absichtlich vorreiter
dass wir die 80 meter links mit dem anti
verschiedene gehabt navigations-apps was
er gemacht hätte wäre so google maps und
die etwa 3 sieg aber mit harvey oder
dort und das thema jetzt nicht super
genau gewusst wie es wirklich schwierig
ist mit einer griechische name und mit
der schrift worden mit wirklich gut vor
gelassen wird für sie sprachen es gab ja
da ziemlich so vorbereitung risikolos
und lewis soll für alle die operation
habe ich wahrscheinlich aber es liegt
das 2 0 fällig besonders zwischen die
hatten hinterher
und er ist vorreiter ist recherchieren
zwischen der richtige also internet
wikipedia podcast apathisch und gut
verschlossen oder 40 grad fenster kam ja
nur große kritik wie hilft diabetes
ökowelle wütender ort ist wo man über
die ganze stadt
trotzdem dass mir das nicht sie ist sehr
spannend ist für touristen fällig wurde
muss sich genießer und wir hier vor der
aussicht eines mitgliedstaats lege ich
dir zum beispiel und jetzt statt
das war die einfachste und hans g
das muss ja vor der schritt erst großes
thema bei verstand so dass das verdienen
indem er einfach ist die situation aber
geht es zusammen zu erleben bis damit zu
entdecken und das macht spaß mit
promoter score gut versteht keiner
erzählen kannst du ja
vor der vereidigung geschworen
der gartenvögel aufbruch können hier
betroffen
links
[Musik]
und das ist ganz ähnlich
der bisherige wurde hier das ist klar
erwartet
aber besser aussehen muss ich habe das
hauptstadt
ja
schon vor der ziellinie kapuzen über
genau denn dann ist
der später von der macht gut
ja ja jetzt haben wir zwei
bei
ja
hallo ich das gas station zum 126 50
musik
hat dort am 6
wohin wollt ihr zum textilmuseum
amerika
das taxi das ist nicht der rechte fuß
ist aber exakt 250 habe damit hatte sie
zwar kein bus und muss sich nicht mit
100 meter gefahren und wie sie sich mit
genau hat für dazu die richtige station
ja ich jetzt
hier
ok danke danke
der kirche
b
er hat sich in die 2 aber ich schätze es
extrem also ich jetzt extrem die
unkomplizierte art die flexibilität des
nehmens dass das irgendwie wieder
verrechnet bestimmen ja wir hatten aber
auch die momente wo mittel aber für
kraft gab es wieder eine situation aus
einer schnell unkompliziert muss gespürt
auf rang drei
hallo
[Applaus]
das größte rechtepaket jetzt erledigt
hier irgendwie passt was von mir
vorstelle zum konzept das man das museum
für blinde und sehbehinderte besucher er
erlaubt es der schweiz oder die anderen
ordner häufig sie die sach und
dienstleistungen für bürger
sehbehinderte sie vielleicht gar nicht
überall barriere für das relativ kleine
sache dass man man.etr das kommt
trainer metro
grundsätzlich soll das minicar wer ist
freund digital anja solid von animusx
kontakt hatte so der plüschtiere effekt
dem sinnvoll oder dazu effekt dass man
auch einfach aus alleine oder sein ding
ich glaub ja schon immer gern aber ich
glaube in andere kultur und glied papier
ist auf wo sie vielleicht nicht wissen
sprach war nicht englisch weiter und ich
probiere sämtliche hof führt darum wird
ist super wir suchen jetzt doch viele
museum
ich werde sie zum museum führen das ist
fragt die vize-präsidentin also ich
führe sie zum museum
messi ist blind side blind
da sind wir also lassen sie mich ein
paar dinge über das museum sagen das
taktile museum hier wurde 1984 gegründet
es ist eines von vier oder fünf museen
dieser art weltweit
das spezielle hier ist dass wir alles
berühren können
sie sind sehr charakteristisch für die
klassische zivilisation
sie haben nur die nase sie haben keine
augen keinen keine not keine haare
nichts vielleicht waren sie mit
leuchtenden farben angemalt
sie gehört dem louvre museum und sie
wurde auf milos gefunden einer
griechischen insel kos lektor oberkörper
ist nackt unten sehen sie und hier ist
sie
sie hat großes rang führt aber nicht
mehr ganz objekte drückt und drückt ihr
nicht so kommt spürt unbedingt hier
sondern mitgespielt habe ihnen auch
schon dicht so dass mit so lange das
braucht er schon noch vertrauen finde
ich weiß nichts mitbekommt und glaubt ja
die angelsächsische für diese normal
wenn sie eine nackte stadt wo haben
wissen wir dass es aphrodite ist wenn er
sehen die person vorsorge statt durch
steht den rückzieher im haus kommt zu
sagen und auch eine der langsamsten look
der vielleicht wird's gemacht und ich
überhaupt von visitator und dieses jahr
wird er heuer mit der hang ins detail
erfassen also fast immer dass details
nach student der sorte training als
ganzes vor dem start
das heißt
musik
[Musik]
vorne
[Applaus]
danke das war kein griechischer liegt
aber ich bin griechen also ist es
vielleicht doch ein griechisches lied
danke ich werde meine hand und was ist
das für ein instrument wollen sie
versuchen zu stehen das mit dauern
ja ich gebe es ihnen in die hand hier
sehen sie und sie hier in you
und hier ist das instrument sind die
nutzen es ist das eisen
[Musik]
ich glaub mir läuft doch es war spieler
das den besten also die blende für gibt
es gratis
sie sind mitten in einer tour es heißt
schon hinaus gehören ihm zu kein problem
brauchen sie hilfe des basiert wie
stimmig gespürt mutter bist von deiner
stehen und wir biegen links ab
ich gehöre zu einer gruppe
hier ist eine absperrung
aber wenn sie ihre hände etwas
ausstrecken kommen sie näher
[Musik]
das ist wahrscheinlich von fries es
nicht
sollen wir weiter
was wir sehen ist der rand des
parthenons und deshalb 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
und es sind immer noch teile der
skulpturen übrig nur die ganze
mittelfeld möglich konkret was das
extrem gut gemacht hier ist es ein
bisschen steinig
wir schauen jetzt in richtung
der stil ist es die spitzen der säulen
sind anders sie haben
ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher wie man
die nennt korinthische verzierungen
glaube ich
lief ja
also eine schmale erstmalig sondern
stärker sondern der mystery bedauern
dies sehr schwer gemacht hat jeden fall
hin
also für die steine von der maut ergriff
land zeitweilig sichere ausflug war
idyllische orte
ich bin froh dass maxi oder abonniert
also ja
enria letzten jahren
[Musik]
trotz tiefer ja
er rät ihnen jetzt irgendwo ihnen
dank claudio pizarro aber nicht die
schweizer wähler verspielt beschluss das
rückständige sprachen scorpion leitet
das menü oder prozess von gail des rates
mustafa guide beziehen und jetzt das
offensichtlich nicht geben und peter
motorrad und marcel schäfer
sie können den pin eingeben
sie möchten ja fragt wieviel 2 200 punkt
60 c max i das upgrade oder sagt andreas
kurz gefühlt habe beim schlussakt
ethisch ist gut so du nutzt facebook
dass das hat extrem viel strom also 260
franken
riechen sie die noten bestehen so diana
fertiger gehen sie diese straße runter
links und dann rechts
dort ist ein weiterer fussgängerstreifen
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
in sachen
entscheiden sie auch kirschen
[Musik]
in schweden zu kühlen
wir sind an der endstation hier ihr
könnt mich mir kommen die jungs merken
ich habe angst zu schwimmen weil ich
keinen schweren körper habe
die menschen würden
nein sie sind jung sie sind schön schön
sie auch keine angst aber ich bin alt
alles hängt
[Gelächter]
jetzt einen kleinen schubs neben deinen
freund es war sehr schön euch
kennenzulernen lädt erste frau
[Musik]
für mich vor dem athen schon nächte
bleiben auch die freundlichkeit von der
analyse die manche wo im koffer die
gemütlichkeit vor dem start einer straße
mit einer kaffee mit einer straße
musiker sie für das die stadt bezeichnet
das glück servicepaket hier glauben dass
es mit gedanken mache wie soll ich zum
beispiel halte aber ich werde nicht
irgendwas falsch machen sondern dass sie
einfach mal hilfe
[Musik]
und jetzt werde ich mit
aber schauen wir noch flache ja gut ich
bin halt leben winkel im integra wäre ja
bereits die show und größte am schloss
natur direkt verknüpft muss ich das
gefühl hätte den krachen aber als sehr
gesellig begegnete sie so
unterschiedlich sie und wie sie hat nur
so sehr oft überhaupt periodic sagt
eckhardt vielleicht liegt es auch jede
kultur das mitglied hat das thema
literatur und so die rics angst dass ich
irgendwie junge schön- schon interesse
umsatzdaten erzählt ägypter aber nichts
war schon mal bis zur wahrscheinlich
weil das ist spitz wird passieren würde
sagte geithner
jetzt mit uns gemacht wurde durch sie
damit ja auch die kultur da oder nach
ganz anders ausgeschaut hat ja es gab
ein politiker ist nico verkauf des
schlosses berlin habe ich glaub
berlinisch völlig andere kultur und dass
sie extrem gespürt dass so üppiger
direkte vielleicht mit herzlich aber
dafür war anders der spd liegt
ja
heute sorgen zwei drittel einen 2
hier ist doch
hat es hier ein lichtsignal
spox ihr ein lichtsignal
ich habe jetzt nur auf
doch was erlaubt
das in berlin darf sogar entdecken
geschichtlich berlin war mir sehr
interessiert wie selber das also wie
fest wurde mitglied euro trägt der
soffin geliebt habe und warum man das
sagen
ich muss einfach toleranter man darf ich
doch leben gerufen
bitter
[Musik]
ja ganz gut
mit 60.000 red
mit der 84
ja von einer maschine
leider verhält er schon
das gilt
[Applaus]
gute manieren hat das tier ins kichern
wenn sie dort irgendwie soll nach wie
vor der maschine auf der iss
so könnten wir mal wie schön sie das
berlin
damit sie auch bei die die rossoneri
logo was auf der welt passiert und
deutschland spielte direct crossover
möglichen thema und da schaut heute
gespannt vom fernseher wichtig war die
situation nicht und bis zu ganzen
geschichte
womit für crysis berlin zeigen wo ist
nicht meine vorstellung
die spanischen sind komplett
sind nach 50 metern also bei der bereit
ist raus geld und die schweizer
botschafterin unsere botschaft ist neuer
botschafter die möglichkeit eigentlichen
merkel ins büro zu lügen
reichstag ist seite so vor der pension
hart bis viermal so groß jetzt
bundesbahn zu groß
genau so dass tatsächlich vergleichbar
also wie zunächst abwarten was da ist
nur relativ harmlosen noch ein hobby ist
die alte große so fühlt sich die
deutsche politik haben
steinig ist
es entstehen dass gespielt die er so gut
also ich verstehe ja genau oder
überzeugt und dass es nach dem zweiten
weltkrieg das subjekt vorne vom atrium
dass dies die musik so dass man direkt
spüre untermieter klaric dazu als das
zweite gold etfs seine position bei also
dabei wird leicht gemacht gesteht sie
haben gestern genau und warum das wird
ein echtes dass man das jetzt irgendwie
da gehört oder sagen wir meistens los
dass man das neue aber gespürt da wird
schon mal das gibt er sogar
dreidimensional frei ja genau
[Musik]
und durch den stempel so ungefähr genau
ist eigentlich mit dem mit dem rücken
zum reichstag sowie ihres staates ja und
darauf vor in dem film eigentliche mine
richtig oder wir jetzt hier so die ihr
ins gesicht fiel mit dem hintergrund ist
schön genau als mal eine kurze
einschätzung deutschland im vergleich
zur schweiz
die ersten eindrücke aus berlin
[Musik]
die deutschen sind sicher direkte wir
haben es schon bemerkt ja vor allem auch
die schweizer in berlin die gefallenen
sehr gut
ich habe besser sein könnte sei
[Musik]
es gab der britische mini sind noch
dabei
ja
[Musik]
was die dem thema sehr cooler ist
ehemannes flughafen chek etwas mit
reduziert berlin zeigt die beste adresse
für regen fließt
[Musik]
jonas schöner witz magath mit bezug
diese endlich sehr schönes ging
wichtiges zu hause sondern nur noch vage
jetzt ist der dandy tusk sehr adrian
arnold veränderung eines unfalls machen
die noch verletzte boys chemnitz
zusammen
nichts drauf
euro
ich glaube erst wenn ich habe es noch
voll ist natürlich haben
da ist also das nein erweiterungen
schmieden
das gericht bestätigte kam gauck ja ja
schon nach vorstellung verfahren und
machen wie noch erinnere das an sagt ich
habe gesehen immer noch gesondert blaue
oder gelbe vorstelle auskennt vielleicht
weiter noch länder von dem kann ihnen
sagen wie gut wenn wir das noch ein
vorstellen aber es half mir das bild und
also zu wichtig statt
zum glück sind sogar so liegt so nah
schien dann jetzt wissen also wie teller
oder das ist aber das ist sicher lieber
gewesen wenn ich zwei meter auf der hut
vor chinas zu machen und vor der
marianne war stets das gefühl es ist
sehr hell und das muss jetzt endlich sie
darstellen bis 3
hallo wie günter schäfer guten tag ich
bin der autor dieses bildes okay
diesen text ja dieses lager basiert auf
dem grundgedanken von frieden und
einheit aller für sie ist eine
auseinandersetzung mit dem erbe aller
deutschen generationen dem zweiten
weltkrieg ein mahnmal gegen jede
faschistische tendenzen
doppelpunkt reichskristallnacht 9
november 1938 mauerfall
für einmal das dunkelste datum die
kristall nicht einmal starte
die mauer
wann haben sie es gemacht eben märz 1990
und jetzt kommen sie häufig noch
verdauen und so weil der inhalt das bild
das gefällt nicht gelten und ich werde
sehr oft heftig zerstört ja und bis dato
habe ich das 62
also ich hatte sie zuvor im kopf dass
man darauf dass für mich ist sexy wie
nett vorklasse so ist es klar dass ich
das nicht mehr
[Musik]
die
die wirklich gut
ja
[Musik]
mit
hersteller
da wir uns machen
dieselbe stärke
aus stetten links
[Musik]
das tor
ja
[Musik]
doch linienrichter aus der arena berlin
schottland geht hier ja hallo freundlich
hallo selbst war in dem gruppe ja ok
berlin ist weder startet live 20 tonnen
fahren
tandem fahrrad velofahrer schäden
relativ ried meister des tempels gespürt
da wind aus erlangen hat hallo ich bin
ich freue mich hallo wer ist jetzt von
den beiden selbst blut die fragt
erleichterung da werde ich der jugend
aus der bild dazu
hört man hier gerne du sagst dann noch
wenn ich mehr oder weniger mit
abendessen
ja
[Musik]
kommt jetzt gleich auf einen berg
oberberg die nazis eine partei schulen
gebaut und nach dem krieg der ganzen
trümmerschutt vom zweiten weltkrieg
wurde hier auch gehäuft war
die dichte und dann den vorangekommen
wer also nicht in rente gegangen bin vor
auf fünf jahre versucht weil ich davon
gelesen haben wir den bergpreis
ja genau
wir haben dann natürlich schon noch mal
ganz zusammen als berlin
aber wirklich so war auch die ein kurzes
berliner verwalten
ob der saft wird das ist extrem stolz
berlin allgemein für grünflächen
die frankenberger freunde ja auch auf
die großen oft auf den rücken alle
zusammen oder ein toller
die typische berliner ist sehr offen
zugänglich auch ansprechbar und
zugewandt aber er ist eben auch vor laut
und frech man darf sich von dieser
robusten ansprache die man da darf man
sich nicht einschüchtern lassen und in
der hinsicht ist pelli nachrichtenportal
statt ich war mal
[Musik]
es wirkte wie du dich die hotspots
risiko
hallo
das kommt jetzt schon drei euro die
karten dass das sind 5
die gruppe hat nein nein werde ich
vielleicht möglich dass uns jemand wenig
die so ein zwei gebäude zeigt wieder
herantasten können war gerne natürlich
dem modell park bietet die möglichkeit
dass manche gebäude sehenswürdigkeit
tauschte die gebäude aber sehr so groß
dass man sich normal auch lina teil vor
der mode zum beispiel reiter stellen wir
das im reichstag gemacht und da ist hat
cooler master bekommt oder das ganze
gebäude erfasst oder schreitet jetzt auf
das brandenburger tor zu mit der
quadriga und den säulen und die beiden
nebengebäuden und dahinter ist der
streitwagen mit der göttin und dem adler
obendrauf als siegeszeichen
es ist spannend er erwartet das
brandenburger tor recht groß ist und zu
erklären
pompös und befasse enttäuscht wenn man
so im verglich die andere gebäude hat
spüren lässt dass brandenburg knapp 110
ist ja das ist der reichstag daheim
genau da stehen wir auf der wiese auf
der großen wiese vor dem genau ist das
stehen wir auch gerade und schauen
direkt von vorne auf den reichstag
aber cool ich habe nur die die mauer ist
schon nachgebessert werden die kommt mir
spüren
und da steht man sowie sowie steinbilder
sowie steinplatten und das spürt man
hier auch sehr gut
ja genau das nötig verdammen oder
anderen seite da momentan lebt also dass
daran in europa haben dem deutschen volk
und dem nationalpark spüre ich schon
öfter geschwungen
[Musik]
ja genau
ich hab ja super am anfang hat dank dir
vielleicht für trees for android apps
aber zwei szenarien abgestellt dass ich
nehme für sie interessiert und alles
widerfahren ist nix gebäude zeigt und
zurück unglaublich gelaufen ist
geschockt er kunst
[Musik]
ich gehe
red
danke curry 36
schöne tänze jetzt los yakari 36 kenne
ich ja seid ihr gerade beim
bürgermeister jetzt bisschen nach rechts
was sollen wir nehmen also die schlange
momentan ist sehr sehr lang also seit
mindestens so schön auch wenn nicht
jeder anstehen ist sie schlagen gelang
ok
studenten der brand machte der skizze
[Musik]
die theorie
wir hatten große einfach erst jetzt
langsam hand ausstreckte hier ist der
fischzucht bildern
hier ist die gabel dankeschön endet der
teller dann ist die brust finden
ich glaube in der iss die gerne spricht
so spezielles sie also liegen wir ja die
fachjury unter wurde ja gerade so gern
ganz normale bratwurst agrarpolitik
welche wollte
1002 sagt meint ja
freilich kaum erwarteten sitze da legen
sie schon sie gar acht groß ja es steht
noch nichts aber der deckel des
schönlings ja ja ja ja das ist heute
gegenstand gehen hoffen dass die ecke
gehen
[Musik]
rene gartler bringt es ist spannend dass
der decke die größe jetzt einfach von
seehofer stoppt strauß gelandet
[Musik]
die ordnung
ja das handy nass
[Musik]
ja
ja ja
da kommt ja ich finde schon optisch
größer die große fläche sei wichtig dass
das so verbraucht sind
denen ist das blöd wenn wir das widmet
ist es ist basti frau sehr gute saison
symbolischen charakter
[Musik]
er hat für berlin wirklich positiv der
sieg erklärt meerrettich berlin moskau
ist technik sondern also mit der
landschaft die mutter war wofür wir
extrem blieb das treffen mit dem
künstler seit die ganze geschichte mir
damals auch lena gebracht oder faßberg
gebracht das hat wirklich mekka aus als
erwartet
der politische status morgen gleich noch
nicht ausgesagt hat dass das reizt mich
bald mit der haltung der berliner schau
dir stadt war mir auch und der bewohner
um ihr wahlrecht auch ständig hobby mit
einer stunde wie gut dass mein browser
aus politisch ja ja das stimmt sagt zu
wenig platz auf mitte oktober weiter
gegen das gesetz vorsieht
aber so zählen
da
fertige ruhe da hätte ja und politikern
hotspur schlagfertige argumente sich das
muss jetzt führt die reise organisiert
und jerusalem
normalerweise findet eine stadt wo die
verschiedenen religionen der haut von
konflikten kommt morgen
wie gut dass die liedteile entwickelt
braucht mitgliedstaates altstadt wartet
die straße wartet jetzt könnt ihr gehen
[Musik]
so erzeugen
die
im raum in dem rad statt
sorry so ist das ja faktoren genannt
willkommen in palästina das hier war
einmal palästina
jetzt ist das israelisch
palästinensischen kapitel links ist das
christliche viertel und rechts das
armenische eine israelische sim karte
konnte für wie viele tage
[Musik]
er muss euch einen fairen preis machen
er haut euch nur ein bisschen über
suchen so mein freund kann ich dein
handy haben
ja
öffne das blut schafft vertrauen aber es
ist ja meine gemerkt man muss sich ja
erst der sache geholt oder unterernährt
das ist das passwort
seid ihr zufrieden mit ihm ja schon
forsch wie wenn man das nicht hätte dann
würde ich mir gar nicht erspart
[Musik]
tja wie bahnhofs glas verheerend sein
ja
[Musik]
geb
das jetzt
nein nein ihr müsst hier runter und dann
links
wenn ihr möchtet kann ich euch
hinbringen
den namen heidi stern im moment
[Musik]
ja ja ja
goldfavorit
[Musik]
optisch erinnert das alles hat es druck
durch aber entwurf
chef des crash
wollt ihr zur klage
ja genau in meine hand in meine hand die
jobsuche nein ich bin tour guide
ja man braucht nicht immer aber auf dem
kopf ihr kennt aber auch eine kippen
wenn ihr wollt
den hut könnt ihr auf die kipper tun
ja aber ich verstand nicht genau wir uns
in der kita aber das betriebsklima
gedacht dass die gesamtgröße glücklich
und das ist nur ein teil vom kopf
bedeckt
das ist die klage nun fragt sonst
einfach um hilfe das ist kein problem
ok schönen tag
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist doch so religiös ort der salome
deshalb erstellt
haben
der hier noch mal vor dem 100 ja der
islam
ich lebe in israel aber ursprünglich
komme ich aus paris spricht die
französische sicher jeden montag und
donnerstag nehmen wir die tore heraus
wie alle juden und so hat es heute auch
viele war mit 2
[Applaus]
[Musik]
damit weist wie die erstkommunion bei
den katholiken
mit 13 jahren wird hier der junge zum
man vorher trägt der vater die
verantwortung für die taten seines
sohnes ab 13 jahren trägt der sohn
selbst die verantwortung
alles alles gute
[Musik]
ich habe geglaubt die monat
ja
gehört das ganze in die natur die ritter
haben wir ein vorfall befragt fürchtet
die rezession das internet andere
vorstellt
das papier mäckler und unter huber und
und tankten mit ihr vor ort als termin
ist erwünscht ruf
ein start nach mass
es ist dafür wird glaube ich das nicht
so mussten wir mit einem vier gang
[Musik]
das geht das gros tags
das glaube ich dass es neben mouscron
allee ob der bedarf dafür stellt das so
der potash
situation aber katy sind in thüringen
haben so wolpert friedhof
gewünscht diese sekret die amour die
hebung glaube schon sehr stark drei das
mit also dass sich der basiert ist schon
dran das ist dass es die macht geht und
darum hoffen natürlich dass die wünsche
in erfüllung gehen
[Musik]
seit der globalen
die aktie von dollar
für jan das hier sprachen es gab of
wales vor lässt was auf dem bildschirm
steht und das macht es möglich dass
meine ersten mal schwieriger schluss
sicher handliche bedienen
damit sprach es gab gegen schnell wurde
gestellt und die arme verstöße also
schon extrem langsam sprachausgabe
brauchen
mit krone.at alle taxi
hallo sie darum blind nicht zu euch
nicht konnte nach vorne
23 auf dem posten
[Musik]
außer lena
hallo
da kann man gemacht
zitiere stoxx hinein aber zehn meter
weiter vorne wartet ein erfolg ja ja
kein problem ich habe gewartet
[Musik]
ja
warum darf der luft
braucht die hilfe ja liebe was man da so
auch selbst sehr viel
es ist sozusagen die gesamte sicht auf
die altstadt von jerusalem
im zentrum ist der felsendom estland
seine kuppel ist ascot
[Musik]
wir sind auf der seite des jüdischen
friedhofes
auf der anderen seite des tals unterhalb
der stadtmauer befindet sich der
muslimische frieden also weiterhin gute
reise
mit der sense eben auch systeme der welt
[Musik]
eingeschränkt
zwei geschäfte
[Musik]
normal
das gleiche sie ja da ich doch muss ich
habe ja
[Musik]
darüber hinaus biete
das geld aus
lauter
hier ist der humus
das butterbrot und hier verlaufen
toller film
st
hier gibt es damals
der stark
von monika am zuckerhut
ja ja
ja wo laufen sie hier vor
[Musik]
münchen
ja
jetzt sehen wir haben hier oder da ich
danke
wie sieht er aus rein zum stuttgart am
eingang würde mit dem vorfall sperrte
das selbstverständlich eine regionen
zusammen schulter und quasi auf null
zurück mit im internet recherchiert und
lag schnell dann ihre website gefunden
und so ziemlich zum rosenkrieg
ich habe euch ein kleines geschenk
mitgebracht eine mütze von unserem club
schutz vor israelischen
also ich erzähle euch mal etwas über den
cutter man club ok jerusalem tut nur so
als ob es eine stadt wäre aber das
täuscht
es sind drei städte eine für menschen
wie mich nicht orthodoxe eine weitere
statistik der muslimischen und der
christlichen araber und die dritte
statistiker orthodoxen juden
jeder teil hat eigene schulen
einige haben sogar ihren eigenen alle
haben eigene nachbarn eine eigene kultur
und eine eigene sprache
es sind also drei städte außer jetzt
dass das jeder tut group at nein da
kommen wir ins spiel
wir versuchen an ort zu sein an dem sich
die drei kulturen der stadt treffen
können
es ist sehr kompliziert aber wir haben
fußballfelder in der ganzen stadt und
schulen mit denen wir arbeiten
von den israelischen siedlungen bis zu
den arabischen stadtteilen ganz im osten
was habt ihr denn schon alles gesehen
sehen ist vielleicht nicht das richtige
wort
ich spürte wie heißt der kunstrasen ist
schwierig darauf zu spielen trainer vom
jugend hektar erhält sie auch
palästinenser muslime und richtet
palästinenser nun ja aber es hat araber
ethiopia jede kultur ist vertreten
palästinenser könnten bei uns beitreten
aber wenn die palästinenser einem
jüdischen klub wie unserem beitreten
bekommen sie probleme mit ihren leuten
in ihren stadtteilen
deshalb nehmen sie nur an den
inoffiziellen aktivitäten von uns teilen
man darf auch nicht in der israelischen
liga spielen wenn man keine israel id
hat wollte er mit einem arabischen vater
sprechen
weil ich brauche ist englisch arabisch
hebräisch und französisch und ich bin
ich habe mal gespielt aber jetzt bin ich
46 und ich bin anwalt der alltag ist
schwierig hier mithalten
wir können nicht ignorieren dass die
situation hier nicht einfach ist
es gibt viele konflikte aber wenn die
menschen in sich drinnen den spirit
finden um zusammen zu leben dann können
sie zusammen bleiben
wenn wir die politik beiseite lassen
dann können die menschen ist gut haben
miteinander und das schönste beispiel
dafür dass dieser fußballclub
[Musik]
spannend wäre aber sehr sehr religiös
ist meistens oder ich leider das sehr
die sender sofort overbeck und
vielleicht sei sie unschuldig
labour-politiker der muslime oder sogar
über polizisten und das quer mini und
deswegen jährlich noch schön zwingen ist
eine große vorteile dass man nicht
urteilen
der vormittag bringt wasser braust die
firma super argument von nordamerika
politik sie dass das einmalige erlebnis
tief das gefühl vorsorglich auf dem
wasser können
lecker dass das gerät
[Musik]
eigentlich 40 minuten aber manchmal hat
man kann die häuser sehen auf der
jordanischen seite des toten meeres
wir fahren nun richtung jericho
das ist eine straße für alle die
palästinenser können sie benutzen aber
auch diese rallye weil sie in die
westbank geht aber auch zu jüdischen
siedlungen führt rechts könnt ihr die
mauer sehen zwischen israel und
palästina grant
der checkpoint
nein weil wir in diese richtung fahren
auf der anderen seite schaut mal da es
sehr viele autos sie haben einen
palästinensischen pass
ich gehöre zu den arabern die in
jerusalem leben
wir haben entweder einen iranischen pass
und eine israel id oder einige haben die
israelische staatsbürgerschaft
jerusalem apa
es ist sehr schön und speziell ein segen
ich bin hier geboren und unser haus
gehört meiner familie seit der
jordanischen zeit
wir werden unsere häuser nicht verlassen
aber sie ist man sich nicht auf
schwedisch sehr schwierig sehr
aber was können wir machen wir müssen
geduldig sein
naja
ich habe viele israelische freunde weil
ich in einem hotel gearbeitet habe es
gibt auf beiden seiten gute menschen und
schlechte auf beiden seiten
nein nur die politik ist das problem der
politik sind die menschen egal
sie kümmert sich um anderes es geht ums
geschäft
[Musik]
erst sehr interessant was der machen
mode zeit und wir das akzeptiert das
labor oder vielleicht doch ein
erheblicher gut die art tracht das
verzerre die harmonie entsteht mehr ganz
so lange gebaut werden die welt
verstopfen die finger schwierig
[Musik]
es ist 10 grad heiß in jerusalem
warum der wagen die höhe
ja wir sind hier 400 meter unter dem
meeresspiegel ihr vorne reiten kinder
auf einem kamel
wow es geht hier räume denn einfach ging
vitrine guides mehr oder dort immer noch
ein paar schritte machen
ihr könnt schon etwas reinlaufen
macht doch mal da mal ein wenig
st
[Musik]
er ist ein freund von mir er hört euch
helfen die schuhe könnt ihr hier lassen
[Musik]
wie ist es sich handle grossartig ihr
werdet jünger aussehen nach
genießt das ich bin hier wenn er raus
muss
[Musik]
unglaublich ja so super gefühlt er den
herzlichen empfang niessl
die schwarze masse der din en sich so
unglaublich
platz
niki lauda
[Musik]
grades und gemeinden
nein da müsst ihr links nach links da ja
hier
was das mit karotten
den weg genommen
damit gern sagt seeler haus angefangen
von der probe dreiheit gemacht und hat
eine untersuchung dass das ganze lebt
[Musik]
möchte das schon mal die erste challenge
zählt auch das gut
hi fis titan lied begann
rufen sie nicht davor in die kameras sie
außer frage - blockiert
zur kritik steht der spaß ganz im 6 in
einem meer und einem toten war sie vor
ganz ohne weiteres grandioses apotheker
im japanischen kunden
darüber und über die asse
naja das ist für die acht wichtigsten
eigentlich ein typisches beschleunigen
hat eine im raum wohl gegessen
dort starb
meine ablehnt flog danke ich für mesums
großes wunderbares projekt jansons
fotoalbum oder sogar schon wieder
aneinandergeriet
[Musik]
mit blindem trauer
zunächst habe der eismacher muss jetzt
auf sell
da musst du dir noch eins gesetzt vom
rechten weg nach links eigentlich mache
ich das schön schön zu nehmen und du du
du lachen
es drückt ja dass sie das kind geboren
sind
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der verstorbene
wer hier herum